[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATE FISCHER: Hi, everyone.
My name's Nate.
And I'm here from
the WebView team.
And I'd like to talk about some
modern WebView best practices--
or as I like to call it,
using WebView like it's
2018, because it is.
So before I dive into
what's modern with WebView,
let's talk a little
bit about what's old.
So WebView's been around
since the very beginning.
It was added back
in API level 1.
And it changed in a significant
way starting with Lollipop.
It became updatable--
the implementation was.
And this was great,
because it meant
that users could benefit from
security fixes and bug fixes.
It would update every six
weeks just like your browser.
But a lot has changed
since then, too.
We've added 40 new APIs
just to make it easier
to work with WebView--
to help developers.
OK, but what's really changed?
Well, when we look
out at the ecosystem,
it seems like apps are kind
of using WebView the same way
they've always used it.
And when you look
at Stack Overflow,
the answers are
outdated at best.
They certainly aren't
best practices.
And oftentimes,
they're just wrong.
But some of the blame is
on our shoulders, too.
Our API docs are written
like it's still API level 1.
And everything has
changed since then.
So something that we did is
we looked over the past year.
And we looked out at
the Android ecosystem.
And we looked at the devices
that are out there today.
And what we found is
that, although we added--
for example, on Nougat, we
added all these great APIs.
A lot of apps can't really
take advantage of them,
because they only run
on the Nougat devices.
And that's less than
50% of devices today.
And it's been over two
years since it came out.
But what we also saw is
that almost 90% of devices
are running Lollipop,
which means that they're
taking WebView updates.
And it means that this WebView
implementation on the device
actually implements
all these new APIs.
They just aren't exposed
on older platform levels.
So we thought, can we do better?
So over the past year, we
worked on our AndroidX library.
We launched a new
AndroidX library.
And we're pretty
excited about it.
And the basic idea
is that we're going
to bring all these
brand-new developer APIs,
but we're going
to try to give you
the device coverage you need.
And we're going to support
Lollipop and above.
We're going to do this by
leveraging WebView's update
cycle.
But we also spent a lot
of time on this library
to make sure it's really usable.
You can actually use these
APIs to do productive things.
So we designed them to be fairly
straightforward to swap out
from the frameworks APIs.
So this all sounds fine.
But how can we actually use
this to make your apps better?
So let's take an example.
Since the very
beginning of Android,
we've given apps a lot
of power to customize
WebView's behavior.
And in particular, we
added a callback called
shouldOverrideURLLoading.
And the idea behind
this callback
is that you could choose
to, for certain navigations,
cancel these in the
WebView, and dispatch them
to a different app, instead,
as an Android intent.
So the example is you
might have YouTube URL.
But that might be better
suited in the YouTube app.
And this sounds great.
A lot of apps took
advantage of this, actually.
But there was a
problem with the API.
We didn't get it
right the first time.
The issues that JavaScript
can trigger navigations.
And what we found
is that there's
some malicious JavaScript
out in the wild
which actually tries to
exploit this app behavior.
And from the user's
perspective, they
might be reading
some web content.
And all of the sudden, without
necessarily their interaction,
it starts opening up some new
Android app that they're not
trying to open.
So we actually already
fixed this issue.
We fixed this back in Nougat.
The idea is we exposed this
notion of user gesture.
Did the user actually
trigger this navigation?
And it actually worked
really, really well.
But it only works on these
Nougat-and-above devices.
And these before-Nougat
devices are still vulnerable.
So we thought this was a great
candidate for our AndroidX
library.
The idea is we're going to
expose this user gesture,
but we're going to do it all
the way back to Lollipop.
And this means that
you get this device
coverage for all these devices.
And you can provide the safe
experience to your users.
But we also made sure that this
would be really easy for apps
to override.
There'd be no confusion.
So I think we succeeded.
But let's take a
look at the code.
So before Nougat, here's
what a lot of app's code
might have looked like.
We're overwriting-- should
override URL loading.
We're setting a WebView client.
And in the body of this, we
might be dispatching intents.
And this is the insecure
version of the API.
But back in those days, this
was the best we could do.
Some of the better apps out
there when Nugget was released
might have something like this.
So you're overwriting the old
implementation from before.
And this is for those
before-Nougat devices.
But for the new devices, you
have this new implementation.
And we're checking user gesture.
And we're not launching intent
if we don't have user gesture.
So this seems great.
But it only runs on a
small number of devices--
even today, only 50%.
So here's how it
looks with AndroidX.
And the first thing
I want to point out
is that almost nothing
changed on this slide.
And I think that's
really beautiful.
It means all the
code that you already
wrote to handle the
old framework APIs--
that code's all the same.
The only difference here is
that we're importing or WebView
Client Compact class for
our AndroidX library.
And we're setting
this compact client.
And the idea here
is that, when you're
using the compact client, all
these callbacks will get--
instead of only invoked
on Nougat and above,
they'll actually get invoked
all the way back to Lollipop.
So you're going to get
the device coverage you
need to provide your users a
safer experience without really
changing a whole lot of code.
This is just one example what
we have to offer in AndroidX.
So I'd really like
to encourage you
to go check it out,
and see how this can
help you make your app better.
We're giving you
the device coverage
you need to actually
use these APIs.
But we're going to have a
lot more APIs available.
Some of these are going
to be small improvements
on classic APIs,
like we've seen.
But some are going to be
for entirely new features,
like Safe Browsing.
And the best part is that this
isn't some soon-to-be-released
library.
This is already out there.
You can go home, and you
can add this into your apps.
And it's ready to go.
So you can try it
in our 1.0 release.
Now I'd like to take a minute
and shift gears a little bit.
So we've looked at
the AndroidX APIs.
And these seem great.
They're going to give us new
APIs with pretty good device
coverage, almost 90%.
But what about these APIs
that have been around forever?
These have 100% device coverage.
But some of them are
kind of hard to use.
Even I struggle to
use them correctly,
and I work on the team.
So a common use case that we've
seen is loading in-app content.
And the idea here
is that you want
to display some content
in your application,
but you don't necessarily want
to fetch it over the internet.
You want to just compile
it right into your app.
But you also want to continue
to build this content with web
technology.
You want to use HTML,
JavaScript, CSS.
And WebView's had pretty
good support for this.
In fact, we almost have
too much support for this.
We have so many APIs that
it's hard to figure out
which one is actually
the right thing to use.
And some of them have
some weird gotchas that
make them kind of hard to use.
So I thought maybe we could take
a look at some of these APIs,
and talk about what's
so tough about them,
and recommend some
best practices.
You don't have to start
from scratch with a new API.
But you can tweak how
you're using these.
So the first API we can
look at is loadData.
And the basic idea here
is that this is going
to accept some HTML content.
It accepts it as a string.
And it's supposed to
display this in the WebView.
But one of the gotchas
is it doesn't really
accept HTML content.
It accepts encoded HTML content.
The idea is you need to escape
some special characters.
You replace them with a percent
sign and a code following it.
And we call this
percent-encoding.
And this is the default
configuration for the API.
But there's actually
no framework API
to do the
percent-encoding for you.
It's kind of an oversight.
But the end result is
that what we've seen
is that developers
tend to actually do
this percent-encoding
by hand themselves.
And this is manual.
It leads to bugs.
And these bugs can have
significant impacts
for your application.
One small bug might
seem OK today,
but it might break in
a future WebView update
if you forget to encode
a particular character.
The other issue with
loadData is this thing
called an opaque origin.
So when your
content gets loaded,
it has what we call
an opaque origin.
And this means that it's
going to fail all same origin
checks in the web.
And these same origin
checks are actually
critical to providing
powerful web APIs securely.
Without these same
origin checks,
you can't use great APIs
like XML HTTP Request.
So what can we do with this API?
Well, first off,
we actually escaped
some of these
encoding-related problems.
It turns out this API has always
accepted an alternate encoding
scheme called Base64.
And this actually isn't that
special of an encoding scheme.
It's just a different scheme.
It's not necessarily better.
But it's kind of nice,
because there's actually
a framework API which will
do the encoding for you.
And it does it correctly.
Great.
So there's
Base64.encodeToString.
This will take the content,
and spit out the right answer.
And frankly, the only
reason it's not documented
is because this came out
in API level 8, which today
is ancient history but was
still in the future at the time
of writing loadData.
But we can also take a look at
these same origin restrictions.
So the way we recommend
to get around this
is to use something called
loadDataWithBaseURL.
And one of the nice
things about this--
I think of it as a
feature, not a bug--
is that it actually
accepts content as is.
You can actually give it content
that's even totally un-encoded.
You don't even have to
worry about the Base64 stuff
if you use this API.
The other really
nice thing about it
is that it has this
thing called a baseURL.
And although you're displaying
this HTML content you pass in
as a string, the baseURL
configures this origin
that it operates with.
So you can control
which origin you
get without disabling
important security settings
just to make APIs work.
So how do we actually
choose the right baseURL?
So this is something that
even I struggle with when
I try to use this API.
I know it's the right
thing, but I actually
don't know what the right
thing is to pass to it.
So I actually thought, how
about we go through some
of the common use cases?
So something that we've
seen is that a lot of apps
use cached content.
This is content they
may have downloaded
from the web over the internet.
But they're saving it for later.
And now when they show
it, they need to show it
with the right baseURL.
And the right URL
that you choose
is just the original
URL that it came from.
This guarantees that,
if it worked originally,
it's going to have
the same exact origin.
And all the APIs are
going to continue to work.
The other use case
that we've noticed
is that apps tend to ship their
own content, and display it
this way, which is great.
What we recommend is that you
choose a real internet-type
URL--
one of these HTTPS
or HTTP URLs--
and it should use your
organization's real domain.
And the reason for
this is so that you
can import other resources
from your servers,
and use them in this
content without worrying
about any same origin checks.
It'll all work.
Then there's the question of,
well, do we use HTTPS or HTTP?
So here's a little
rule of thumb.
We always want to encourage--
HTTPS is the secure protocol.
But if you do need to
show insecure resources,
we'd recommend that you use
the HTTP scheme, as opposed
to disabling important
security settings just
to get your app working.
And as the last point,
I want to urge apps
to avoid custom URL schemes.
So this is something that
we've noticed has cropped up.
Apps will make up their
own scheme, and use that.
But the problem with this
is that the web standards
don't really expect
custom URL schemes.
So they're very vague
about how to handle this.
And it turns out
that they wind up
getting handled
very inconsistently.
And this can lead to
surprising app breakage.
So if you can stick to one
of the internet URL schemes,
you're going to have
a much better time.
So hopefully, I've
expressed that we really
do care about developers
at the WebView team.
And we're trying very
hard to make sure
that you have powerful APIs that
have the device coverage you
need, while also
paying attention
to some of these old
APIs, and making sure
that we explain how
these need to be used--
making sure that
they're actually usable.
If you have any questions,
me and my colleagues
will be around for the rest
of today, as well as tomorrow.
And we'd be more than happy to
talk to you about WebView usage
and what you need
for your application.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]